se prendere questo prendere
ciao a tutti nei minuti sono i fattori
del nuovo challenge con la nota alla
nota per i giochi detto il tecnico è un
concetto questo challenge è un po
particolari po diversa si chiama forse
l'avete vista sudamerica dal pit
challenged line dan peek challenge cioè
buttano slime cialde ogni modella russa
capiterà da un fit quindi buttano slime
che ho creato fino a quel momento dovrò
buttarlo nel secchio di vitale se capita
a me e se capita tetto dovrei aiutato
nel mio secchio quindi è il vile
schifezza lo posso buttare nel turate
loro vino ma non ti rimane niente però è
chi vince e c'è lo slime più bello
certo come sempre per questo stiamo
usando i tempi perché sesamo le sue
trappole tava problema con brano in 15
lasciato un bellissimo i temi le altre
challenge slime con la ruota considerata
seni commenti che fare con una nota
mettetevi comodi pagati e pop corn e
imbrattati
questo proprio in un bacio che potrebbe
portare subito in semifinale base 900
visto niente per ragioni slide non ha
pagato e non subito più carta poi mi
cercando carta poi vicinissimo tosi
perché ha mangiato cioccolato quindi
pieno di zuccherino allora dimmi se gli
to me quindi ovviamente senza anche una
bianca così a una buona base ma che con
gli splendidi capi di faticose a si
speri che ti capiti e non solo per
l'edizione zero sterline
quello che buttano compagnia all'inizio
il montaggio perché già scavallato via
quello trasparente e quindi finora
stiamo con la bianca con artissima si sa
[Musica]
di già
cambia quindi è normale quando vorrà
chiamare problema piazza savona con la
bianca che anni firma copie è stato
detto che dipende da ieri perché la
studiamo ma chiediamo un aiuto su
youtube
non posso scegliere quello che voglio
dove per forza scegliere una colla
quindi io scelgo la colla bianca per
continuare il fatto non solo
[Musica]
50 ma si carica la gente è una penitenza
parte ma non so niente io mi sa proprio
cosa devo dare un voto per te perché tu
rimane senza niente a lato c'è la
tracolla tracolle capriva mega strand
gigante bellissimo in più uscirà anche
grossi perché c'è la roma con l'altra
sfere territorio sono fortunato
stranamente non scorgiamo buttiamo
giambuzzi aver dato tantissimo a colare
sugli archi transparency nei meriti non
possono essere cosa allora in pratica si
fa a colpi di calibro tra parentesi il
mio breve bellissimo libro è ancora
scontato sua prima che mi sta piacendo
una somma maggiore mandando le foto e mi
ha detto che le ricette sono bellissime
quindi sono stata contenta che vi sia
300.000 e sementi descrizione per
ordinarlo su amazon se vuoi prenderlo
anche tu
a proposito di libro di compatta che al
tema come mi avete regalato un talismano
contro il breve
ora me lo metto vediamo se tizio
down e tutto il verde che mi avete
regalato contro il male distinte
perfette cioè coloro vedo qui il mio non
ti ho detto è verde
appunto perché se tu hai già reperti
addosso non ti capita liberty vediamo
diminuzione ieri l'ultimo mischiando
grossi amuleto non è che mi devi portare
sfiga è destro proteico tutto per bene
perché mi riguarda è sfiga ci sarebbero
investita oggi si 22 30 sono presenti
potrebbe rimanere un piccolo io sono
tenuto l'incontro lo slai cobas non
cantare vittoria perché in questa
challenger si vince si perde si rivince
seri perde altri big three bet è bello
perché ho detto che per ultimo
[Musica]
devo scegliere colate a un giochino
bravo perché potrei aiutare in verde
cinque colori quale spero che mi capo
spero quindi tanti giro di quello degli
occhi e tattoli nato quasi mai
no quello no
[Musica]
la croce novi fino a quando a
disposizione da cellino ma basta
credo ok
grazie rosa che bello che bello anche se
portarlo piace tantissimo ai mezzi
bellissimo vediamo con l'aspetto aiuto
ok ci sono almeno miracolo
sono indeciso se prendere questo o meno
male il bottino
parte così non posso neanche la spizzata
di colore giallo voglio farlo a quanto
pare però 3 enorme la stava per capitare
il buttano nuovamente ti amo in
conclusione capi di questo caso dove
serie qualsiasi cosa o chi quindi
chiamati col secchio
quasi tutti se non li ha saputi ma sono
ok sono questi non ha funzionato come
titolo forse la volete un telethon per
colorante non quelle decorazioni questo
ci sta insomma già funzionato una volta
ma pure laterza ta come possibile dello
ricaricarlo come questi non vanno bene
con
si vendono in blu vitale piano piano non
sta creando molta piano piano non so
niente
[Musica]
sì
oramai fra i vantaggi tantissimo questo
slancio giocoso che bello che bello
tanto vuoto palli e senza un papà dai
poi se gli elettori non i fondi del tuo
slime è fatto solo di palline qua nel
frattempo sta crescendo sempre di più e
gigante vacatello girone palline con
questa come folla giornata per gambe
[Musica]
le palline
eppure rosa
solita fortuna che lascia miller
adesso va bene ma era veramente scambi
la situazione lo dividono veramente
bellavia raccogliendo tutte tutte le
pareti e sulle pareti per pagare un
[Musica]
piccolo è nato grazie
finalmente di nuovo il mio marito carte
[Musica]
da mangiare la butta la maledizione
chiusi chiudi gli occhi per chiedergli
anche cosa tu chiudi gli occhi e devo
dire fare un occhio e aspetta ok puoi
per stare ma questo colorante su cui
prendere qualsiasi cosa stanno bene e
altri cosa cosa hai preso di torneo è
messo questo qui non ci posso credere e
dai letti chi teme di questa situazione
attuale io oi residui quindi uno slam
minuto ed italiano tanti campi e ora
anche queste guide merito ma diventa ed
è tutto merito tuo
non cantare vittoria ancora no anche
bello ribelli che colori bellissima
volte poi dire la vita dicono siamo
molto ora stella o cambia o puntano così
al menu mero un bel drive
voglio una trasparenza con parente così
fortunatamente anche a me ossia lo sly
[Musica]
con angelozzi chiusi ma quindi alla fine
ce li avremo diversi ma che se così è
allora che vi gli occhi belle questo
aspetta tutto sto facendo da 12 frati
vediamo un po come diversa quindi
facciamo cambiarmi facciamo prendere un
bel colore
[Musica]
eppure proprio colore del mio team di
blu è più bello il mio si sia più bello
il mio e ora andiamo ad attivarli
potrete votare chi vi siete praticamente
marche ecco qua il mio slam
pensavo sarebbe uscito molto più piccoli
invece non male sentite che allora il
colore è uscito un rosa molto chiaro
perché era molto diluito poi le canarie
ha buttato comunque rondò molto chiaro
con i glitter e anche le palline poche
palline di residuo viola
in più non ha molti ingredienti quindi
come poking fa poco booking popolo potro
topping perché di schiume da barba non è
aveva insomma non aveva quasi niente
praticamente solo con la bianca e con la
trasparente poppata consolle che carino
un filo rosa timaru allora che voto date
al mito ai box da una 10 sia per aspetto
che per turisti per i commenti stiamo
tale eco il mio eroe giustiziate un mega
puffo lo stesso per la foto è enorme il
colore è stupendo
bellissimo lo attivato troppo poco
perché avevo paura di rovinarlo e quindi
si attacca un po alle mani
però adesso piano piano lavorandolo
lavorando della destra fuori dalla
bibbia non sto più chiaro registrato del
solletico
guardate queste norme
io sì è davvero stupendo tutto merito
tuo grazie ride grazie mi hai fatto
vincere la casa l'insegnante downey
morta non è veramente enorme che evita
che ha visto in alto anche molto bello
mi piacciono molto il colore del nord i
giochi misti naif l'afoso penso proprio
piace scegli enorme enorme
ecco io ho vinto vitale e votate votate
mutate e ora vi lasciamo a quattro casi
li street che se volete vedere
scola ruota la vita di fermezza e
[Musica]
chiarezza